en clair obscur c'est le titre du nouvel
album proposé par françoise hardy ça lui
va bien puisque toutes les mélodies sont
en demi teinte autour de la nostalgie où
l'on retrouve aussi bien etienne daho et
hip hop des chansons composées d'il ya
longtemps comme tu ressembles à tous
ceux qui ont eu du chagrin
c'est en 1970 et puis un premier titre
déjà beaucoup pour donner un hommage à
mireille interprété comme un film
d'amour puisque vous partez en voyage
présentation olivier dénoue drive avec
basile mesdames messieurs bonjour
puisque nous nous quittons ce soir
que ressent on apprend des seuls
j'aime
une gare le rendez vous des amoureux
d'un couple heureux qui rend hommage à
mireille et jean sablon
du coup droit
pour les grands signes ou des hommes
j'ai préparé mon gros joie
la fuite du temps des sentiments des
belles années
un voyage en clair-obscur clair obscur
le type du dernier album de françoise
hardy
ce qui est clair c'est un disque c'est
un disque et tout ce qui est autour du
disque pour moi c'est obscur et ça
m'intéresse pas vraiment quelques à
pouvoir santé le plaisir de françoise
hardy
selon jacques dutronc parler
sérieusement vous vous moquez de moi et
vous vous permettez de lui poser des
questions parfois on pas jamais dire
jamais en finir la pauvreté réponse soit
l'acteur m'échapper parfois j'oublie
qu'il ne faut pas lui poser de questions
enfin comme je ne réponds jamais donc le
ton dimanche contre les socialistes
david bowie été soudaine pour mick
jagger elle incarnait l'idéal féminin
bowie jay guerre et iggy pop autres
sales mômes du rhum
philippe ravi de chanter avec hardy
l'égérie des sixties
elle sort un nouveau disque mais ne se
considère toujours pas comme chanteuse
n'aime pas savoir refuse de monter sur
scène
françoise hardy poursuit tout simplement
son voyage
par des gens
je
serai-je blanc
une échappée sentimentale plein de
mélancolie